[Music]
school choice has proven consistently
popular among one very dependable
constituency parents and unpopular among
another unionized teachers the rapid
spread of school choice over the past 20
years has triggered an increasingly
fierce union pushback setting up an
inevitable clash enter an insidious yet
helpfully descriptive new term in
policymaking controlled choice yes you
parents still get to choose your desired
schools but public education bureaucrats
get to control the final outcome and
lately from New York to San Francisco
Charlotte to Polk County the only
criteria that matters is not student
performance but race New York City
schools got a little less segregated
this week my local city councilman in
Brooklyn wrote at the beginning of this
school year the winner is everyone well
about that in 2007 the Supreme Court
barred school districts from assigning
students to schools based on race so
instead they use income as the primary
determinant and characterized the
resulting admissions changes as
desegregation the goal is to have poorer
kids homeless kids and english-language
learners
spread out evenly among schools while
crossing their fingers that parents
won't bolt and that all schools will
improve when this system was tried in my
home district in Brooklyn it ended up
being hellishly complicated the team
that designed New York City's school
picking algorithm literally won the
Nobel Prize for economics though fun
fact one of those designers didn't like
where the system placed his own kid so
he opted out and chose a charter and I
don't blame him one bit the good news
this year is that kids from communities
that had never even considered some of
the high-performing schools both applied
to and were admitted in higher numbers
school choice for the win but turns out
parents don't much enjoy being
controlled one size fits all schemes may
look good on paper to progressives but
when applied to their own special
snowflakes suddenly lefty parents start
sounding as skeptical of central
planning s FA Hyack or at least quietly
eyeing the exits after more than a half
decade of sustained increasing
enrollment my district sixth grade class
shrunk by a whopping
and percent this year what happens in
Brooklyn alas doesn't stay in Brooklyn
the same policy process is underway in
Queens and parents there are already
revolting the New York City School
Chancellor is not winning many new
converts to these changes with this
habit of calling skeptical parents
racist there's an equation to diversity
and a lowering of academic students I
will call that racist every time I hear
it and I will say it so if you don't
want me to call you on it don't say it
meanwhile the city is considering a
mandate that would require every
traditional public school have roughly
the same racial ethnic and
socio-economic makeup within ten years
good luck with that
parents of means can always take the
expensive options of private school or
physically moving to a new district but
the main off ramp for the non-rich has
been New York's extensive charter school
system now just guess what kind of
schools New York politicians are placing
an artificial cap on
so how has controlled choice worked out
there in the world the Cato Institute's
David Armour looked at a half dozen
controlled choice districts and found
that enrollment went down richer
families fled and schools didn't even
end up more integrated so a friendly
reminder here from the People's Republic
of Brooklyn controlled choice is an
oxymoron top-down systems look bad from
the bottom up choking off supply then
browbeating demand is no way to run a
service New York and other cities would
be better off allowing more competitors
to provide public education and more
choice to meet the idiosyncratic needs
of a challenging diverse and high
achieving city
[Music]